you're one of my favorite guests you're
one of my favorite uh comedians
and your career has just taken off
you're in a zack snyder film
you're playing jet reno in star trek
yeah
it's insanity it's madness
got a little gas you got a little gas
you know what you really do have action
hero energy coming off you right now
and it's really helped by the fact that
your feet are
dangling off the chair
meet jet reno everybody i haven't even
talked yet
i know um
[Laughter]
you know my wife gives me a hard time
about this because i do i sit
really far back in a chair and a couch
and my feet dangle is there any way i
could get a um
like a little stool or something to put
my it costs money
no i'm willing to pay that's fine look i
got action hero cash now
please is there a little something yes
oh good oh my god look at this
that is oh thank you so much
okay
why are you still moving your feet
i'm excited to be here you've
accomplished nothing
you know um i'm delighted to see you and
seeing you here reminds me that we've
been here at the largo theater for how
long flanny we've been here
we've been here a year flannigan your
sidekick flanagan
is working hard to replace andy richter
uh flanny as we call him runs the largo
theater
and that's what working hard looks like
uh yeah and he's wearing his true irish
colors uh which is apparently a neon
pink
yeah um and uh but you know flanny well
because
you perform regularly here at the largo
theater before the pandemic yes
this is like your second home you must
have very strong memories of this place
i do but this is uh what if i didn't
remember anything
like nothing rang a bell well that's how
i feel about this pandemic
anything beforehand is a vague memory
yeah no it this is
i mean is it cheesy to say my home away
from home yep
okay well that's what i'm about is
cheese
but it really is my home away from home
you perform here all the time
not just that let me tell you something
you might not know this
but um after my mother passed away i
inherited
her furniture and so
all of her pieces were around her house
and stephanie my wife was sick and tired
of the couch
and she was like listen this has to go
we have to get a new couch at least
and so i had a hard time parting with it
and so i thought you know what i bet
flanagan would let me store it uh
backstage at largo
so that's the blue couch that's been
behind you
on all your episodes that's my family
couch
this is your mom's couch yes and then
you gave it to flanagan thinking can i
store it and of course
now it's a tv star it is a t
[Laughter]
you should see the fan mail i'm gonna
put that in the background of my action
films and tv shows now
it's yours to take you know what i can't
believe is flanagan
has filled this theater with i don't
know what else to say
knickknacks bric-a-brac garbage garbage
and junk
i was convinced that what is happening
back there
we shoot this [ __ ] what is that noise do
you hear that
yeah it's on the street well we're right
off the alley i know we're right off the
alley hello come on in who is it
i wouldn't say that because people have
yeah seriously who is it come out and
show yourself
who is it it was another truck unloading
something
i like how my [ __ ] here is ridiculous
there's an alley right here
and we're trying to cover it up by only
a curtain yes
there's there's and my interview is
getting directed at a truck driver in an
alley
yes you're like hello hi how are you say
something
you're here i'm over here being an
action star
in the number one movie in the universe
and you're like talking to a truck
driver in an alley
that's the level of show business we've
seen you don't know what you have i
don't well i do know what we have it's
just we're next to an
alley and i swear to god they're
constantly there it's like there's a
bowling alley next door it's insane
that one sounded like people fencing
something yeah
there actually is a bowling alley next
door